[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today uh
today's question comes from Tess in
Arizona I'm looking to buy a new car
soon I'm seeing lots of incentives
almost $2,000 off Wi financing I have
the money saved so what if Oh Boy George
I financed for the discount then paid
off before the first note is due of
course would I be charged interest or
any other fees is this considered debt
genius okay Tess yes this is considered
debt I don't know how you could say I'm
financing and it's not debt now what
you're saying is hey I have the money
what's the big deal I'm just taking I'm
being a smart consumer getting the
discount and then I'll pay it off
immediately well there's some things you
have to consider here number one when
you're financing the dealer can throw in
a lot of different extra fees they tack
on there but they've distracted you
right with this little carrot they
dangled which is the $2,000 off oh yeah
you can hear it $2,000 off off we don't
know we don't actually know what a good
deal is in this scenario until you
really look at the numbers and you start
and once you're at that point Ken once
you're across the desk in the financing
office the part's over they know they've
got you oh yeah it's a lot of pressure a
lot of pressure when you get in those
offices and there could be pre-payment
penalties cuz they know people are going
to do this and so they say hey you can't
pay this off within this time time frame
and the other thing is the lender the
financing office loses the commission if
you pay it off in a short window yeah uh
so there's a lot of things there to
consider and if you have the cash I
don't know why you're messing with that
I think you're going to get a better
deal and honestly I would run from that
dealership uh it sounds like you're just
seeing this incentive online but I would
go get a better deal elsewhere a
reputable independent used car dealer
you're going to get a better car there
and when you said new car yeah I know
that's also a big that's a big trigger
for me Ken there's only a few people who
should be buying brand new cars and that
is folks with a million dollar net worth
and no debt yeah because the hit you're
taking on depreciation is insane new
cars lose 60% of their value in the
first 5 years yeah and uh I just did a
video on this can on my YouTube channel
of course you did get this nine days ago
and it's called why is why is no one
talking about America's wealth killer
and it has almost a half million views
and people for once are agreeing with me
they're going big time half a million
view I think it's because people such a
Hot Topic well of course it is yeah it's
you know everybody's driving around the
cars and you know what else they say
well Ken I mean used cars are as
expensive as new cars these days not
true it's wiser to just buy a new car
yeah it's crazy that's insane by the way
you know all this like hubub about
electric cars have you seen the prices
on the electric cars insane now you
bought a used one very yeah mine's 10
years old yeah and by the way it doesn't
look 10 years old thank you I try to
take care of it yeah it looks fantastic
but uh it it's there's this there's this
pressure and there's going to be a whole
wave of pressure uh to to buy the
electric car it is it is all a big giant
collusion and it's forcing people to
they think well it's where we're going
we got to get one might as well get it
and next thing you know they're driving
around with the $1,500 car P oh my gosh
cuz they're thinking well one day
they're going to force us to drive first
of all there would be an American Revolt
if they forced us all and I know there's
some things in California going on I
can't even count that as a legitimate
State at this point for all the stuff
they're forcing people to do but in the
great state of Tennessee you drive what
you want uh but with that it's your
American right to drive stupidly
expensive cars uh and they're for your
ego don't tell me they're for
reliability and for your children's
safety I just don't buy it I'm going the
other direction folks I'm I'm going to
be driving once I get the kids
everybody's out I've already got you
know I got my classic 72 conver Gia love
that little air cooled engine I'm going
in Old School baby and I'm just going to
putt around and put out all kinds of old
emissions love it just you just take
this emission and shove it you know
that's what I'm going to do old cars you
can't track me because I'm just along
with my little knows where I am at all
times yeah ex he's checking he'll pipe
through my car speaker at any moment
exactly another reason why I wouldn't
buy an electric car there we go well uh
all that to say Tess I would not do it
for the incentive and financing you're
getting screwed and if you and if you
think you're winning you're definitely
getting screwed because the dealerships
are not losing on these deals whenever
they're like well you're really taking
us to the cleaners here my manager's
real upset with me no they never even
talked to the manager they went to take
a smoke break and came back cuz they
knew they got you in the bag I'm so glad
you brought that up you need to do a
video on YouTube on that like walking
through cuz you're what's actually
happening when they do the okay let me
go talk to my manager yeah they're back
there talking about what money they've
put on what football game I'm really
going out on a ledge here for you
manager's docking my pay for this one
I'm not even making a commission really
what a ruse that oh it's exhausting give
me a break this is why I rarely buy cars
cuz it's exhausting when I do I don't
deal with these dealerships no thank you
how do you feel about buying a car
directly from a from a real person
that's where I like to go you know what
we're actually we just filmed a video on
this we're going to release it soon on
buying used cars selling used cars the
right way to do it I think it's great
now do your due diligence don't buy a
used car from a random Joe Schmo and
then yell at us when it's a clunker get
an inspection yeah you can go to
Firestone get this done for 50 bucks
it'll do 120 point inspection the other
thing to do is actually check the Carfax
check the history make sure it has a
clean title meet them at the at a police
station meet them at the bank do your
due diligence when it comes to these
things but once you do the police
station yeah that's a great place to
meet for any
transaction I mean it is but that seems
like a little much I think the grocery
store is fine well you know in your
neighborhood Ken but in my seedy
neighborhood no it's fine